[Music]
okay everyone so this is my spoiler
review
of the new film on hulu originally from
a24 which is
false positive this was directed by john
lee and written by john lee
with alana glazer who stars in it this
also has justin thoro in it
and pierce brosnan what's so fascinating
to me about this movie is it's a classic
movie that makes you feel like there was
so much potential here
a good premise on paper but it's just
not
executed to what this could have been
and
i think that really feels that way
because if you're like me the first half
literally
of this movie kind of gets you intrigued
you're liking how it's going the
performances across the map all the
actors and actresses are really good
cinematography is solid i even like the
direction here
but there's a lot of issues with this
script and how they planned out
this film and one of the biggest issues
that came off to me right away
was that we know way too much ahead of
our main character
right from the start you can figure out
from the first five minutes that you
can't trust this doctor
and that you cannot trust adrian the
husband
the problem is is that if they're gonna
sell us that
at the halfway mark we have this big
moment where our main character
of lucy decides you know what i don't
trust this doctor anymore
and i also think my husband adrian's in
on it that did not feel earned it felt
earned from the audience perspective the
stuff we've seen like
they show certain shots of adrian just
like up to no good in his office and
they show this way too early by the way
giving away
what's really happening and giving us no
suspense but the problem is
is we didn't see all this through the
perspective of
lucy and that's why it doesn't feel
earned when she starts to figure things
out and i feel like the story could have
been way more
effective if we were getting everything
from lucy's perspective
straight from the beginning and her
slowly finding out little things about
what's really going on and not just
handing it to the audience but
i just cannot get over if they're gonna
do that and make it pretty predictable
that they wouldn't try to show it
through her eyes more so it makes sense
when she's kind of catching on
everything
where they kind of just sell it by her
having you know some visions
when she's asleep and maybe hearing
things but it really wasn't convincible
to me at that halfway mark that she's
figured it all out so that was really
frustrating and this is a huge
issue with a lot of hollywood projects
right now as everyone's trying to be the
next get out and
why it's really hard to pull off the
genres you better be really good
at social commentary and your themes and
everything has to be clicking with
characters
but what hurts about that genre is that
any vibe like that
you can't give away that everyone's bad
right away because then you get rid of
suspense like it's getting too
predictable now you know who the
villains are
they're acting weird you could tell by
the nurses here like dawn you know she's
got her hair in a bun she's
blonde hair and she's acting all peppy
you know she's off so
it just takes away from mystery to what
you think would really be going on i
wish
they can kind of do a better trick into
it where it slowly starts to reveal
itself what's happening and when you
just show it
right away come on you know that's just
a key to make us really kind of start to
zone out and things start to get silly
here and believability like dawn comes
back for the magazine
that lucy took and he's like dr hindle
wants it back now we know dr hindles is
villain
he's this mastermind right he's got his
ideas why on earth would he
risk giving away what he's doing by
weirdly asking for a magazine back that
was completely silly
no one would ever do that and they do
some reveals here that
feel cheated like how they had a reveal
that
the doctor was using his own semen here
but we saw a scene where
adrian with lucy not around so he wasn't
doing it to show face in front of lucy
gives his semen
into a tube for dawn here and he's
watching abusive porn
this was a trick to me because again it
wasn't serving it
to show lucy so you're like then why is
adrian doing that that was just
completely to fool the audience
to the reveal of it actually being the
doctor's scene and i thought that was a
real cheat and then the other reveals
you saw coming a mile away like of
course
you know we saw adrian want to have the
boys we knew it was gonna be the boy
twins that come out not the girl
that was coming a mile away it was too
telegraphed and we don't really get
payoffs with storylines
in particular in her career storyline
where she's got this boss that
just screws her over and has her taken
off a project she gave ideas for
it's never resolved with her boss and
her career that's just forgotten about
and then what i really thought was maybe
the worst part of this movie
was with this midwife grace hamilton
because
they literally shoehorned in a theme
here right where
they show her say to lucy i'm not a
mystical black woman which is a huge
stereotype in film and tv what if you're
going to do that
how about not show the stereotype by not
doing it in the first place
it was just came off so odd because it
was like
hey we want to make a point and a theme
and a message here but we're going to
tell you it literally speak it out loud
so that just did not make any sense to
me at all you know
you got to do it less on the nose like
come on now that
just was like so unearned as a moment
you don't make
points like that through television and
film you got to show it not tell it so
that was
criminally bad and i still didn't even
feel that much payoff with grace
hamilton's
storyline or we really got to know more
about what her end game
and goal was the end of the day and that
she was just kind of there to serve the
plot
and shoehorn this theme in that just
really felt
forced because it was what lucy thought
when she was drunk that she was seeing
this mystical black woman so it didn't
even make sense with what they were
trying to give a message of about
racial stereotypes and putting that on
somebody so that was just
really uneffective i'm ranting back
because it was just the most odd thing
i've seen in the film in a while
and i think it's so tough with heart
because you want to make it dark right
you want
you're going to have sick uncomfortable
stuff but i don't even know if this
really landed where
you know they trick you thinking she
dropped the twins out the window in this
peter pan flying style
she doesn't but she gives them to adrian
and i thought that worked but then
having her
breastfeed the dead fetus of wendy was
just if you're gonna go that far i don't
know if it was necessary if it really
was the landing piece this movie should
have landed on because i think that's
just a result of it being a weak movie
anyway so i felt like a lot of this just
felt really try hard this film and
that even comes to how they open the
film with her all bloody and then it
comes back to that shot we've seen that
done so many times
again just more to take away from
suspense and what might actually end up
happening because they're giving it to
you all in the first
couple minutes however i did say i
really did actually like the first half
of this film and then
you kind of see a lot of mistakes little
mistakes and made in the first half
crumbled on itself and
really made to me a really bad second
half but it wasn't the worst movie i've
seen
i saw a lot of people really hard on it
i didn't think it was terrible it was
still
watchable and i think that also goes to
you have a great cast here i was really
impressed with lana glazer in particular
doing a serious role i think she did
really good yeah i just wish that the
story itself
had enough to it and i feel like this
was missing a couple rewrites this felt
like almost like a first draft of a film
and these things could have been patched
up and made better and that's why i just
feel like i had so much potential and
just a letdown
so i'm actually going to give this one a
5.9
wish it was higher i had high
expectations for this and
it's interesting because 824 usually
doesn't have bad stuff but it makes more
sense now that they gave
off this to hulu to release as a hulu
original because they probably were not
confident
in this one so let me know what you
thought down below i'd love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment
try to respond as many as i can please
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
one of my reviews i do a bunch of movie
reviews
tv reviews i also do celebrity
interviews as well and if you really
love what i do here i really appreciate
if you can become a member today
you'll see a join button down below
under the video and you can become
exclusive member to get exclusive perks
and thank you for joining me and i'll
see you next time